[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled Advanced mRNA vaccine
solutions by genscript this webinar is
part of the fifth annual event in the
bioprocessing virtual event series I'm
chrisel of labts and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labroots and sponsored by genscript for
more information about genscript go to
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you like during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
submit we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for at the end
of the
presentation you will also notice that
the speaker has provided a survey
located on the right of the abstract
this survey will be available during the
live and the on demand period if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the help desk
button located at the top of your screen
within the navigation bar or from the
lobby finally as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I now
present today's speaker ran bth head of
SE marketing genscript USA Incorporated
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the presenter tab from the
menu at the left of your screen Roman
you may now begin your
presentation okay thank you chrisy for
your introduction and thank you
everybody for attending our webinar on
Advanced mRNA vaccine Solutions
here is the agenda for our webinar I'm
going to go over quickly about over
types of vaccines mechanisms of action
I'll discuss our mRNA vaccine solutions
from genin script uh I'll briefly touch
on other vaccines protein DNA virus and
what kind of solutions we have for those
vaccines and then uh with short
conclusion so first before I go into
vaccines a little introduction about gen
script gen script is a global company uh
with a lot of services and products we
were founded in 2002 we publicly traded
on the Hong Kong Stock Exchange we have
about 4,000 employees right now and we
are very well known to be number one in
gene synthesis we also have multiple
production sites some are in China some
are in us some are in
Singapore and we have served over
200,000 customers worldwide our
headquarter is in piscato New Jersey
USA and we offer 24-hour customer
service we have fast Global Logistics we
offer high quality and very Innovative
services and
products we have very Diversified
offerings we have uh four different
business units under gin script the life
s C Business unit they offer wide range
of services a lot of their process are
fully automated for consistency
efficiency and they typically work in
the Aro preclinical grade
Services where also have the biologic
cdmo division gcri Pro bio uh they
mostly work in the clinic clinical and
preclinical space they have high GMP
capacity to meet the market demand and
they have very strong biologics
expertise we also have the catalog
products division uh they offer high
quality of the Shelf Regents very
Innovative instrumentation lately they
have been launching many instruments
related to Automation and automating
various lab
processes we also have the synthetic
biology uh business unit best time they
focus mostly on innovating food industry
and they have very broad portfolio they
have very strong Cent D and application
ation
capabilities uh my team we focus on
several different market segments we
focus on vaccines gene therapy Cell
Therapy antibody Therapeutics and ivd
and we work all across all these
business units to assemble portfolios
that are best suited for this market
segments so what is typical vaccine
workflow and what are the typical
vaccines that are on the market
according to the wh website there are
three generations of vaccines the first
generation of vaccine was mostly virus
based those were either inactivated
virus or life attenuated virus then the
second generation was mostly subunit
vaccine uh where antigen basically is
extracted from the virus or is
contracted by genetic engineering means
and those are typically peptide or ACC
comant protein vaccines or virus like
particles and then the third generation
vaccine is mostly nucleic acid based so
these are the newest vaccines we saw the
covid related vaccines were most of them
that came out first were nucleic acid
based so they would be DNA mRNA or
nucleic acid packaged in a viral viral
Vector so what is the typical vaccine
mechanism um the um typically the
antigen enters the cells the human body
and then is picked up eventually from by
the antigen presenting cells and is
usually converted whatever the antigen
the antigen shape was DNA RNA or virus
is typically converted to protein first
and then digested to peptides these
peptides are um in Incorporated to the
MHC qu one and qu two complexes and
they're presented to the t- cells when
t- cells encounter these antigens they
get
activated and correspondingly they
create cell cellular immunity or humoral
immunity so this is the typical uh
vaccine
mechanism and what are the typ different
vaccine types by function typically we
have prophylactic vaccines that are
usually used before the pathogen enters
the human body and they're also
therapeutic vaccines that are typically
used after the human body is infected by
the pathogen
in some examples of prophylactic
vaccines are the vaccines for eboy HPV
ssov 2 we all experience that and some
of the therapeutic vaccines they focus
typically on the tumor ass Associated
antigen or tum more specific
antigens and they're usually cancer
focused however there are some vaccines
that are also now starting to focus on
infectious
disease so what is the difference
between therapeutic vaccines versus
immunotherapies uh for example antibody
Therapeutics they belong to the passive
immunotherapy uh Group which uses
antibody drugs to Target the antigens
and basically they would label the the
tumor cells or the infection cells and
they would create basically attract the
immune cells to kill
them cell therapies are typically um
using engineered cells that make more
efficient cell cells to for killing for
example um te- cells NK cells are
engineered to become better at finding
the tumor cells and healing them
effectively and then therapeutic
vaccines are typically used to educate
the immune system to recognize and
proactively kill tumor cells and more
effectively find them and kill
them in large number of therapeutic
vaccines are currently in clinal in
research stage uh therapeutic vaccines
are expected to be very important
complement to tumor imun
immunotherapies and a lot of the
companies that actually develop cancer
the covid vaccines those companies that
previously were working on therapeutic
vaccines bio bio entech Monna curavac
and hopefully they're going to be
watching their therapeutic vaccines very
[Music]
soon so what is typical vaccine
development workflow typically the
development workflow starts with find
the pathogen identifying it analyzing
the antigens that are related to this
pathogen and basically making decisions
what type of antigen will be used for
the vaccine for example if you take the
covid
vaccines uh decisions have to be made
should the spike protein be used for the
vaccine the RBD domain of the spike
protein combination of the spike protein
with an and protein and so on the next
step is usually deciding on what kind of
compound is going to be used for the
vaccine would it be protein peptide DNA
RNA virus optimization of this compound
for efficiency and then optimization of
the delivery
mechanism then typically preclinical
studies are completed with animal models
um and looking at efficacy in animal
models immune response side effects and
so on and then the clinical stage starts
with different number of patients
clinical trials looking at clinical
efficiency and also the resilience and
how long the immunity
is
proceeding so going back to the
workflow what can gen script do for
antigen identification and selection um
there are usually two different types of
studies depending on the type of vaccine
pathogen study for virus usually the
virus is isolated identified the virus
structure is analized the specific
antigens
identified very often antigen epitope
studies is perform to understand the
exact epitope for the
antigen uh for tumor studies usually
studies are focused on tumor Associated
antigens those are usually highly
expressed in a tumor and very low
expressed in normal cells or tumor
specific antigens that are highly only
expressed in the tumor they're not
Express in normal cells at all tumor
specific antigens are usually the more
efficient way because they come with
less side
effects so what can gen script provide
for this um antigen identification and
selection uh we have genome analysis
products and services for example we can
offer NGS enrichment libraries those are
based on our gin Titan
oool methodology uh we can also provide
PCR and qpcr related products we have
very strong portfolio of PCR enzymes
nucleotides we can develop um custom
primers custom props we can label them
on the protein analysis side we can
provide a lot of tools for protein
detection and quation basically Western
boting Products antibody catalog or
custom um developed antibodies
polyclonal monoclonal Mouse rabbit we
can develop custom ier
kits for analyzing the immunogenic
response we can usually offer products
for epop mapping P peptite libraries we
can also develop customiza kits uh for
detection so going a little bit more
into detail into the different services
so for example for NGS libraries we can
develop hybridization based libraries or
amplion based libraries they can be
packaged in different formats they can
be in tubes or plates they can be leiz
and we of course send them with the
corresponding
documentation these libraries are based
on our Gene Titan on chip synthesis
technology this technology enables us to
synthesize up to 8 million olos in
parallel on single
chip as and usually the coverage is
99.9% so very high and with 20 to 30
milligram quantities of volle and we can
also scale this down we have smaller
libraries that are
92,000 oligos and they can also be
developed very efficiently with
99.9% coverage and 5 to 10 micrograms of
OLS for PCR we can offer variety of
products as they mentioned and we can
synthesize the forward primers reverse
primers we can synthesize the props we
can label the props for
you we can also deliver them in
different formats tubes of plates or
liliz powder we have also DNA enzymes
DNA polymerase enzymes we have excellent
anti-na polymerase antibody that allows
uh companies to create hot start T
polymerases we have reverse Transit ases
dntps and various plasmid
vectors for imuno detection portion for
protein analysis we have complete portol
of Western boting Products we have
excellent sh page Precast gels those are
gels that run very fast they're very
high quality very high resolution we
have the corresponding tanks for running
them we have pre-stain standards we have
the widest range protein standards on
the market from 5 K to 270 kons uh we
also have Western boting Products we
have um EB protein transfer system which
is very very efficient wet bloting
transfer is fast and easy to use and the
same time gives you the ability to very
efficiently transfer your proteins with
wet
bloting uh this can be bundled together
with our easy West automated membrane
detection system that does automatically
the the blocking primary antibody
incubation secondary antibody incubation
all the washes required for that and
gives you a membrane that's ready for
detection uh for gels that are stin
instead of used for Western boting we
also have automated stainer disainer
that can accomplish the whole staining
disain in within about 10
minutes um we also have very high
quality catalog antibodies that are off
the shelf and ready to
ship uh in addition to the catalog
antibodies we can also develop any
custom antibody we can develop custom
polyclonal antibodies custom monal Mouse
monoc coronal antibodies custom rabbit
monoc coronal antibodies we have
multiple techn techologies for antibody
development
including single B cell isolation and
using the beacon platform uh for testing
and we can do also antibody labeling uh
if those antibodies are going to be used
for flow cytometry for example or Eliza
kits we can also label them
correspondingly for you in addition to
the antibodies we can do antibod kit
development so we can develop various
sandwiches elizer competitive elizer and
and so on we can develop anti-drug
elisis anti-drug antibody elers we can
develop Custom hcp kit for your specific
expression system and for your specific
expression
workflow for immunogenicity testing we
can develop various ptite liaries we
have overlapping libraries we have
alanin scanic libraries we have
truncation libraries and so on VAR type
typ of libraries that can be very useful
for testing and they can come with
different um delivery dates depending on
the type of liary that you're looking
for and depending on the peptide
sequence and length of the
peptides mRNA vaccines are
very effective as we can see from the
covid developments they were developed
very quickly and um they seem to work
very effectively however they have some
challenges sometimes during application
they can cause cyto
storms some other side effects could be
allergies renal failures heart failures
infractions therefore they have to be
optimized very carefully they have to be
very care the sequence the structure uh
the delivery mechanism the dozing all
these parameters need to be optimized in
order for the vaccines to be effective
and safe um Vines are also pretty
challenging to develop uh mRNA is very
well known for its stability degrades
very quickly therefore a lot of
optimization has to be done on that part
three prime utr optimization structure
optimization RNA length optimization
shorter rnas are usually more stable
modified urans have to be used sometimes
to prevent degradation from by
enzymes um mRNA translation may need to
be optimized with again with the five
Prime and three prime utr regions five
Prime capping
efficiency the more complete the more
stable and more better translation
efficiency poly tailing is also very
important that's well known and codon
optimization um also the RNA delivery
mechanism needs to be determined and
optimized where would be lipid nanop
particles polymers peptides other means
of delivery um so all these parameters
need to be optimized in order for us to
deliver a successful
vaccine so looking at the MRNA structure
uh we have the five Prime region that
usually needs to be CED to improve the
stability of the MRNA eventually lead to
better
translation uh five Prime and three
prime UT utr regions they need to be
optimized for stability and translation
coding region needs to be optimized with
colon optimization to improve the
translation efficiency the three prime
region usually uh poly a tailing needs
to be optimized uh to provide the
stability and translation efficiency so
all these parameters need to be
optimized and what can gen script do for
your developments basically a gen script
we can go from the beginning to the end
of this process uh we can we have very
good tools for codon optimization we
have already pre-optimized utr designs
that you can use uh we can do the gene
synthesis we are very well known to be
excellent Gene syntheses anything from
short olos to very long DNA
fragments um we can produce your
plasmids we can develop the plasmid
construct it and do watch preparations
of the plasmid uh we can do enzyme
production if needed and we can do the
ivt MRNA synthesis with all the required
modifications optimization of the
sequence the utr regions with the
different uin uh sudo nucleotides and so
on so go in a little bit more detail in
some of those Services uh for example
for Gene synthesis of course we offer a
number of different Gene synthesis
Services uh we can do fast standard
economy Gene briak uh they very
depending on the size of the gene
fragment that needs to be synthesized
the complexity of the gene
fragment um So based on that we would
recommend different Services uh gin
brick is usually used for very very
large fragments that are very difficult
to synthesize a single fragment and we
can synthesize them as multiple
fragments and we also have excellent U
cloning kit that would allow you later
on to assemble these fragments back into
your
plasmid we also offer web- based
software for codon optimization that
makes it very simple and easy we also
offer the G smart design tools for your
da construct U design and optimization
and also of course we can provide
instant quotations on your service
requests so going a little bit more
detail about the plasmid preparation
Services we offer I'm not going to go
over this data I just going to point out
that we have several different grades of
service we have service type for aarg
grade um for basic research industrial
grade for early drug Discovery and
preclinical grade for preclinical study
and those very based on the quantities
we produce the quality of the
purification and parameters we testing
QC and of course all of this can be
customized for your
needs um our genescript Pro bio cdmo
division of course can take this into
the clinical range they can offer GMP
production of your plasmids for mRNA
vaccines for DNA vaccines and so on they
have different grade Services uh plasmid
CMC preclinical clinical and then
postclinical basically production um
production of the
plasmids if you decide that you would
like to uh keep some of these um
operations in house we also offer as I
mentioned initially we have products
division that produces a lot of
innovative products and instrumentation
we can also offer you instrumentation
that can help help you do your own
plasmid purifications Amat is basically
out of the box
automation um it can use one controller
and multiple purification modules each
purification module can purify up to six
samples six plasmid samples up to four
modules can be connected to One
controller so this can give you very
good skillability if initially you don't
need this High through put you can get
one or two two modules and later on add
more modules and they can be seamlessly
added to the
system uh the purifications are very
high quality very high yield Purity and
basically low low endotoxin for
expression for transection level
plasms we can also perform the ivt
reactions and deliver mRNA product to
you uh this is here the usual mRNA
structure usually the cupping needs to
be done on the five Prime region we have
optimized this uh very very to achieve
very efficient capping and right now our
efficiency is could be close to
99.5% very high cupping efficiency you
can see when we compare with some of the
um leading competitors on the market We
compare very favorably for
that so a little bit more detail on our
mRNA service options we can provide you
scale up options
we can produce micro mini and midi from2
Mig all the way to 20 Mig of
mRNA we can also we can also provide
larger quantities as customized
Service uh we can also of course do the
capping
options I'm
sorry we can produce uncapped cup zero
cap one uh we can produce different
versions of poly tailing no not tail
100 aail customized tailing based on
your
requirements uh we can introduce the
modified uans into the uh sequence
structure and customize it according to
your requirements we provide different
purification levels for Aro usually we
use Silica purification with silica
comb for our preclinical grade Services
however we use Silica and then ol
purification in tandem so uh delivering
very high quality product for
preclinical work we can also perform
double stranded RNA removal and we can
customize the QC packages depending on
the grade of the product are you or
preclinical grade we can provide with
different packages that are always
customizable based on your actual
needs Mr Integrity is very important for
expression um here we Show an example of
mRNA EG GFR uh egfp mRNA and ESP C9 mRNA
produced by us and some of the leading
competitors on the market and as you can
see we compare very favorably to these
competitors and um that shows also in
the translation efficiency you can see
on the bottom charts here our mRNA
produced by gen script showed on the
left side for the egfp significantly
higher expression levels and for ESP
class 9 also higher expression level
compared to some of the other
alternatives on the
market for poly tailing of course as I
mentioned we can guarantee and customize
it according to your needs we can
produce very consistent and homogeneous
poly tail uh in this example we
produced mRNA with 120 nucleotides poil
and we compared with some of the
competitors what they produced and you
can see that we compare very favorably
on the bottom left chart you can see the
cell staining basically for egfp uh
signal the green and then the dppy
channel uh for blue and you can see that
our expression is very strong on the
right side you can see the actual
measurements you can see significantly
higher expression with our mRNA compared
to the
Alternatives we have received so far
very good customer feedback um there
very satisfied uh we had feedback from
Cornell University they use our mRNA
Sleeping Beauty trasp it worked very
well for them does the data on the very
top um another customer use our Fook
mRNA and they received excellent
expression and they were very satisfied
with the performance that's the chart on
the very right for look expression and
and Tra Therapeutics they used our egfp
IM RNA made at in Vivo in mice and they
were very happy and satisfied with the
results some of these more popular mRNA
products we also are introducing them as
of the Shelf products for example the
reporter GNA mrnas egfp fuk Lucifer a m
Cherry those are of the Shelf products
now that you can easily order uh
generating mRNA is P 9 UM Sleeping
Beauty ISB 100 trp is also of the Shelf
product you can order those stand one or
in combination of with other services or
products we are also starting to offer
circular RNA uh
Services circular rnas are very novel
molecule for Therapeutics until recently
they were considered as aberant spicing
byproducts and not much about their fun
function was known however now there
have been many papers coming out that
have identified various functions for
this uh circular
rnas um some of the functions as Mr Mi
RNA sponge protein sponge basically
regulating uh translation and so on
various functions and they're very
interesting for therapeutic
development because they offer very good
stability um better stability than
linear Mr for longer expression
duration they for usually higher protein
expression they reengage the ribosomes
with rolling Circle
translation um also the circular RNA LMP
have seem to have better thermal
stability so they're more stable and
more resilient for delivery and um
Logistics so they're being very heavily
researched right now for therapeutic use
you can see the number of Publications
based on Pub metet search exponentially
Grew From a few hundred early on to
several thousands per year in the recent
years so very high interest in using
those for
Therapeutics so a little bit more detail
about circular RNA products and services
we have developed we offer two levels of
services to different quantities micro
and mini uh Point 2 to 1 milligram and
or 1 to 10 milligram we offer different
IR options uh we we offer the typical
public domain cvb3 uh we can also
customize the IR domain for you and
design it based on your
specifications we do typically uh
reverse phase HPC verification so we can
deliver very high Purity and we do
variety of QC measurements to ensure the
integrity and quality of the uh
product so here is example of circular
RNA egfp expression and analyzing by
flow citometry you can see that the
circular RNA performed significantly
better than the same sequence of linear
RNA mRNA also our produced mRNA
performed better than what we saw see in
the literature from other companies
producing such mRNA so you can see the
data on the left uh the expression level
started very high higher than the others
and stayed higher during the uh length
of the experiment and then the day one
and total uh expression level were much
higher we also offer lipid nanop
particles packaging service now for mRNA
delivery as you know well lipid
nanoparticles consist of several
different um components usually
cholesterol phospholipids ionizable cic
phospholipids and PE lipids and those
are usually assembled to into lipid
nanop particles to encapsulate the MRNA
and preserve it for delivery and um
within the
body so here is a little bit more detail
about our LMP formulation service um so
we can package anything from 1 milligram
to 10 milligram of mRNA uh 5 K bases or
less uh usually this is suitable for
intramuscular delivery for animal
studies only at this point for our
service and we can ship it appropriate
conditions Frozen as needed uh and
encapsulation efficiency is higher than
80% and do we do variety of measurements
to show the consistency and
reproducibility of our process the final
concentration can be customized spare
your
needs here is an example of our LMP
packaged mRNA uh one example comparing
of gen script formulations with a
well-known competitor on the market and
you can see our formulations compared
very favorably with higher expression
levels um also um here is shown on the
right bottom you can see the in
experiments were also successful with
injection in
mice
so for preclinical studies usually
vaccine Effectiveness needs to be
evaluated sometimes in vitro uh looking
at exp protein expression levels to
determine how well the molecule is
expressed if it's mRNA for example or
DNA vaccines um then usually immunity
needs to be determined based on animal
models Mouse models monkey models and so
on so cellular immunity evaluation needs
to be performed looking at cyto kind
levels
um Sometimes using elispot or
flowetry humor humoral immunity
evaluation looking at IGG IG IGM
expression um neutralizing antibody
expression um
determinations using either aak kits or
virus or pseudo virus and vaccine
efficacy needs to be
determined so some of the solution gript
can offer for you in the clinical sture
we can develop the molecules for you as
I mentioned of course we can produce the
plasmids preclinical grade plasmid we
can produce ivt mRNA preclinical grade
at very high quality and Purity we can
offer some of the tools that are needed
for the analysis for protein expression
levels Western boing tools custom
antibodies for various immunes custom
Eliza kits for for detection uh for
cellular immunity evaluation we can uh
develop peptide pools and libraries for
you and we can develop also Eliza kits
for humoral immunity
evaluation and this is the summary of
every what we can do for amarina a
vaccines basically we can support you
from the very early stage from antigen
identification regeneration optimization
preclinical studies and clinical trials
uh we can support your pathogen studies
with sequencing product enrichment SE
for sequencing uh PCR products and
services um antigen identification and
and determination basically with Pro we
looking at protein expression imuno
assays Western Bing Eliza kits antigen
epitope studies with custom peptide
libraries we can also help support you
for tumor specific antigens for with our
NE antigen peptide synthesis
Service uh for regeneration optimization
we can produce anything from the genes
to be synthesized Vector construction
plasmid production plasm linearization
mRNA production with all the
optimization that is needed five Prime
capping poly optimization colon
optimization scale up as needed and of
course we can offer similar for the
preclinical studies preclinical plasmid
preclinical mRNA protein expression
evaluation tools immunity FAL immunity
cellular immunity and so on and then our
genp Pro bio division can also support
you during our clinical trials and
Manufacturing with GMP grade plasmid and
GMP grade mRNA IBT production as well as
required GMP manufacturing
analytics so I will also very briefly go
over the other Solutions we offer for
other types of vaccines peptide Pro
protein DNA and
virus I'll will touch mostly on the
services and products that I haven't
mentioned for the MRNA vaccines so for
example for peptide based vaccines uh
vaccines we can offer very wide range of
peptide synthesis Services we can
generate the peptide Library Services I
mentioned typically for vaccine the most
often used ones are the overlapping
peptide or alanin scanning uh
libraries um we can synthesize
neoantigen peptides um for your aays um
high suc with high success rate 8 to 50
amino acids high quality
controls uh we can scale up the peptide
synthesis up to kilogram level if needed
uh we can produce it with high Purity
98% we can keep it with low endotoxin
levels and we can synthesize peptides of
up to 200 amino
acids for aom protein vaccines we can do
a lot of the services I mentioned
already anything from Gene synthesis to
plasmic purification and others I'll
very briefly touch on some of the
services they haven't touched before
like our protein expression service for
example uh we have very strong protein
expression capabilities we have multiple
platforms here I'm showing only two of
them um the Maman expression platform
with either heck or 29 three or Cho
cells or the ecoa expression platform we
also offer insect cell expression
platform bakul virus based but a little
bit more detail on the turbo Cho
platform which is very popular at the
moment uh we have various levels of
service from very small quantities to
increasing level of quantities the hyro
putut CH Express CH CHP that can produce
progressively higher amounts of um
protein
you can see on the bottom the turnaround
time starting from two weeks or 10
business days for the hro put to three
weeks and six to seven weeks for CH HP
for larger quantities they can produce
at very high Purity and very low osin
levels of less than one EU per milligram
of
protein we can also of course do Eco
expression very efficiently we can start
from Gene sequence and finish with
protein delivered in three to four weeks
uh performing the gene synthesis and
cloning the Transformations at hro put
the protein expression at highr if
needed and the protein purification and
then delivering purified protein with
the all the required QC
documentation and again um as I
mentioned for our product uh Division if
you decide you some of those operations
You' like to perform them in house we
can support you with for that also we
have very Innovative instrumentation for
protein purification and antibody
purification um we have fully automated
system for uh purification it can purify
12 samples at a time the samples can be
up to 50 milliliters each and each
sample can contain up to 80 milligrams
of protein or
antibody and typical cycle times to
purify all 12 samples is 50 to 60
Minutes in the instrument is prog to
accommodate different protocols in
different expression TXS with different
purification magnetic beats and illusion
volume can be as low as 0.5
milliliters the main benefits of this
instrument is increased through put you
can purify very high number of molecules
very quickly 60 to 70 uh proteins can be
purified within a day uh we can also
save you time and labor because this
system is based on magnetic beats so
magnetic beats are more resilient to
contamination and so your sample don't
need to be centrifuged and filtered
before the purification so you can use
crates or if your proteins are secreted
you can use the the cell culture inside
the instrument the instrument to remove
the cell cell debris and deliver
purified protein to
you for DNA vaccines of course we can
produce as I mentioned already a lot of
the pl Ms we can start from Gene
synthesis colon optimization we can
produce Gene Circle and um we can
produce the plasmids that you require
and we have a lot of strong offerings in
the molecular
biology
area this is more detail on that
part for viral vaccines we can basically
be end to endend provider again we can
start from Gene sequence we can produce
all the required plasmids for your virus
we can package them in a Cell line and
then purify them and basically deliver
the purified virus either a or
lentivirus depending on your
requirements so basically we can offer
all these services and products from
beginning twin for Gene synthesis
plasmid virus preparation we also have a
lot of products are um related to
specifically to the virus analytics for
example we have lentivirus Eliza kits we
have av2 Eliza kit we have a lot of
antibodies again against AV variants and
we also have some of the virus related
antibodies uh we have pens neuras which
is alternative to the Bonas for
digesting the genomic DNA during virus
preparation and we have BSA Eliza kits
and CH hcp Eliza kits that are ready to
um on on the
shelf for viral Vector vaccines we can
be essentially One Stop solution we can
start from the very early stage with our
C and product divisions supporting you
during that stage and then um eventually
switch this for your indd clinical ande
and preclinical and clinical studies and
Commercial production to our cdmo probo
division that can produce this under GMP
conditions so from beginning to end we
can support you through through the
whole
process and this is my summary my last
slide so vaccines office are very
important for human health according to
the cdcu website more than four million
deaths per year are prevented just due
to the childhood vaccination and many
more due to subsequent
vaccinations um mRNA Technologies are
becoming more and more popular for
vaccine development um very rapid
development process as we saw the
examples with covid and um also a lot of
the technology might be transferable
from one vaccine to another some of the
issues for uh dealing with mRNA
degradation and stability and expression
those could be translatable from one
vaccine to another accelerating the
development Eng script can offer
complete workflow of services and
products for a marinade vaccine
production everything starting from
research to preclinical and clinical
stage we can support you to that either
with services with products with resurch
grate services and products or
preclinical all the way to GMP
production we can also offer very strong
support for other vaccines types such as
peptide protein virus and DNA we have
complete portfolios that we can support
you from beginning to end and uh thank
you for your time and I'm ready now to
take uh any questions that you may
have thank you ran for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of our webinar now to our
audience if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen and we will
answer as many questions as we have time
for
okay let's get started so ran we have
quite a few questions coming in I'm
going to start with this
one how quickly can you deliver
preclinical grade
plasmid so preclinical grade plas can be
delivered within nine business days and
that's only if you order it as a
standable one service if you actually
order it as part of another service for
example our Gene synthesis and plasm
development we can also to shorten the
time for that and it's not going to take
nine additional days it will be more
like a few extra days to deliver the
preclinical great plasmid to
you excellent our next question what is
the amount of plasmid that your
instrument can purify per
sample okay very good question there's
no real cut off of what we can purify
and cannot purify with this instrument
but the performance of instrument the
Purity in the Y is the highest in the
range of 300 MOG to 1.2 mgram again it
doesn't mean you cannot purify lower or
higher is just some of the Ute or the
Purity may not be as high as if you're
in this
range very good next question what is
the size of your mini Circle
Vector the mini Circle Vector is very
small because we have engineered as much
out of it as we could so it's only
429 29 base
pairs we have time for a few more
questions uh let's let's go with this
one can you guarantee low endotoxin
levels for the MRNA
production yes we can guarantee in our
mRNA production in our ivt service we
can guarantee less than 10 EU per
milligram of
mRNA
very good and ran we're g to go ahead
and wrap with this final question here
can you guarantee the a tailing Links of
the
MRNA so we have multiple Technologies
for producing the the a tailing and we
can definitely guarantee the length and
we can definitely meet your requirements
whatever they are
1008 100 days or less or more we can
definitely
deliver and we have very high
consistency homogeneity of our ailing so
that's what I showed on one of my slides
thank you very good thank you ran now do
you have any final comments for our
audience I just want to thank you
everybody for attending our webinar and
again gript is here to support you
through your developments if you're
developing mRNA vaccine or other type of
vaccine we are here to support you with
services and products anything from
research grade to to GMP grade products
or services and again if you have any
more questions feel free to contact me
or contact gin script with those
questions thank
you thank you again Roman for your time
today and for your important research
now before we go I would like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions I'd also
like to thank our sponsor Jens script
for sponsoring today's webinar any
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the on
demand period they will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of
registration today's webcast can be
viewed on demand for two years until
April 5th
2025 labroots will alert you via email
when this is available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event thank you for joining
us until next time
goodbye thank you
bye-bye